ein biere tube für den transport von
gefahrstoffen
was machen sie damit ich hab keine
ahnung haben ein rätsel wir haben eine
bedrohung der menschheit und wir haben
dann das sind so die üblichen rezepte
weg erkennen sofort dan brown ist der
mann der das zusammenbringt und den
bounce film inferno ist mittlerweile
schon der dritte in der reihe nach dem
da vinci code nach illuminati
wir haben wieder zu tun mit dem
berühmten symbologen aus harvard robert
langdon wieder gespielt von tom hanks
und leider ist er nicht in bestform ist
hat einen filmriss licht im krankenhaus
wurde mir einen jetzt bricht eine
spritze wir haben bei ihnen hängen
zugang gelegt alles ging in trebbin ist
wahrscheinlich tot krankenhaus das ist
insofern besonders schrecklich weil ein
menschheit bedrohen das ereignis bevor
steht ein milliardär und wissenschaftler
der in der überbevölkerung das problem
überhaupt für die welt sieht hat ein
erreger platziert oder es entwickelt
dann platziert und wenn er los geht und
wenn er freigelassen wird für die hälfte
der menschheit dezimiert und das muss
der gute robert langdon verhindern
speicher tränen exkrementen das stimmt
mächtigsten die wichtige regionen so
eine solche haben wollen simon ist ein
fehlanzeige und was sie dafür tun dass
die tracht stiftern eine biologische
waffe
die buchstaben das ganze könnte man als
die bewährte denn bauen formel umgesetzt
von ron howard im kino bezeichnen man
sieht eben bilder von florenz wunderbar
von wenig später von istanbul schöner
als sie die fremdenverkehrszentrale
dieser versammelten städte auch jemals
ins bild setzen könnten
ich habe immer das gefühl bei den braun
das jetzt bei entfernen sind bisschen
die innovationskraft aufgebraucht ist
und das ist natürlich vor allem für dan
brown leser ein bisschen schwierig sein
kann ins kino zu gehen denn man kennt ja
alles ist zwar das ein oder andere
ausgedünnt worden ist ein plot strenge
gekappt worden weil man es sonst nicht
in zwei spielen unterbringen könnte aber
es geht immer so ein bisschen wie für
mich die spannung verloren als
begeisterter leser der bücher rätsel die
robert langdon lösen muss wir können da
muss man keinen lehrstuhl in harvard
haben sondern wie kann man eben auch
wenn man kleinen reiseführer ließen
danach istanbul und florenz für chemnitz
von not auch selber höhe
ich muss die buchstaben und stellen
sagte hinrich gute das wirkt bis hin zu
einfach ein bisschen zu transparent und
mein eindruck ist dass in diesem dritten
film ja die große zeit von den frauen
vorbei ist dass er glaube ich nicht
genug variation und innovationskraft hat
um diese formel noch mal ein bisschen
neu zu definieren um sie zu variieren
wir sind über dieses jahr 500 auf der
anderen seite für eine dritte zur straße
runter jetzt noch einen vierten film mit
robert langdon sehen wenn ich bezweifle
dass ich kann mir auch vorstellen dass
tom hanks bis sie die nase voll leid
dass er vielleicht nicht nur mal lust
hat nochmal den linken zu spielen das
ist zwei interessante figur ist auch
hinreichend komplex aber es ist kein
indianer jones ist es kein nerd aber es
ist eine rolle die relativ wenig
spielraum lässt und die für jemanden wie
tom hanks eigentlich eine unterforderung
darstellt sie werden wir sagen wollen wo
es ist ehrlich ich weiß dass wir dich
sagen sie ihm die menschheit ist die
krankheit entfernung ist die heilung